hey everyone it's Warren and we have a
huge reveal today Murch oh it came out
with new officially licensed Avengers
in-game merchandise with this release of
the official merchandise and the
description that they put on their
website of the merchandise comes some
huge reveals about the plot points for
Avengers in-game with this release of
the new merchandise and its description
that came along with it we get some huge
confirmations about Avengers in game so
I'll break it all down for you in this
video quick reminder that I started a
new giveaway giving away five imax
tickets so you and some friends can go
see Captain Marvel or Avengers in-game
in IMAX if you'd like to enter for a
chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain so like I said today merch I'd
came out with some officially licensed
Avengers in-game merchandise
specifically a white orange and black
hoodie modeled after the all-white suits
that we've been seen in all of the leaks
that the Avengers are wearing Richard
calls this hoodie the Avengers advanced
tech hoodie so this officially confirms
the white suits that we've been seen in
all of these leaks it is now officially
confirmed by Marvel because these are
officially licensed Avengers merchandise
so that's a huge confirmation right
there but in the description of this
hoodie there's a lot more to be revealed
so I'll go ahead and read it all to you
the description starts off by quoting
Captain America and the Avengers in-game
teaser trailer by saying this is the
fight of our lives the thing goes on to
say the brightest minds in the galaxy
came together to develop the Avengers
advanced tech hoodie if you're looking
to avenge those lost in the decimation
you'll be needing this so already that's
a pretty huge reveal if you're looking
to avenge those lost in the decimation
you'll be needing this
remember it's referring to the new white
suits that we've been seen that's what
this hoodie is it's the new advanced
tech suits and this line tells us that
these suits are a huge part to avengers
endgame this tells us that the Avengers
will need these suits to avenge those
loss to the decimation and as we read on
more into the description there are a
lot more reveals about these suits the
description goes on to list bullet
points about the hoodie it starts off by
saying officially licensed Avenger
merchandise the new black white red
color combination is perfect for any
possible environment you can or maybe
can't perceive so right they're probably
talking about the quantum realm it's
widely believed that these white suits
are for travelling inside of the quantum
realm presumably for time travel
purposes an environment you maybe can't
perceive sounds like the quantum realm
or possibly maybe some sort of variation
of soul world but most likely probably
the quantum realm and this confirms that
these suits are indeed made for
travelling inside of that environment
and we happen to get a confirmation for
this in the next bullet point in this
description the next bullet point reads
zip it up and you couldn't be more snug
if you were in the Microverse the
Microverse is the quantum realm Marvel
and Disney actually did not own the
rights to be able to use the word
Microverse in the MCU but in the comics
the quantum realm is the Microverse they
just renamed it the quantum realm for
the MCU so right there another official
confirmation by Marvel cuz remember
these are officially licensed by Marvel
confirmation that the Avengers are going
to go inside of the quantum realm and
these suits are designed for doing just
that and as we continue in the bullet
points of the description it reveals
even more the next bullet point reads
look awesome whether you're in New York
Wakanda or in the far reaches of space
and beyond there are many people who
have speculated that these white suits
could actually be for travelling to
space and it looks like they are looks
like they're for traveling inside of the
quantum realm and possibly into space
this makes sense for a couple of
different reasons one they could be
going to search for Titan 2 where Thanos
is that the second is that it's been
said that space and time work very
differently inside of the quantum realm
and that's what it could mean by and
beyond
perhaps the Avengers are going beyond
space inside of the quantum realm or
perhaps again it could be referring to
some variation of the soul world but the
description does say space so these
suits will also be used for traveling
into space the next bullet points read
sports style Tech hoodie allows you to
run punch kick and flip and style sizes
to suit everyone from ant-man to the
Hulk so again another official
confirmation that the Hulk will wear one
of these suits this isn't a huge reveal
as we see
The Hulk wearing one of these suits in
some concept art that was leaked but
again this comes directly from Marvel
and if the Hulk is wearing a suit that
does in fact imply that he will be
Professor Hulk and Avengers endgame the
next bullet point says Avengers logo
certifies you as a real hero again this
is just stating that these are certified
officially licensed products by Marvel
and this next bullet point is perhaps
the biggest reveal of this release it
says materials polyester blend sorry
no nanotech or Pym particles included so
there you have it this officially
confirms these suits are going to be
made of nanotechnology and they're going
to incorporate Pym particles its
nanotech so we know that Tony Stark
himself is going to make these suits no
one else really knows nanotechnology
it's too advanced even Bruce Banner
didn't know so this officially confirms
that Tony Stark makes these suits and
again it confirms that these suits are
in fact for traveling inside of the
quantum realm because it uses Pym
particles and this is most likely what
the circular devices are that we've seen
on the hands of some of the Avengers
those devices are most likely for
holding Pym particles so they can shrink
back down inside of the quantum realm
and the last bullet point ladies reads
that women's versions are available of
this hoodie so there you have it huge
reveals from the release of this
official Avengers merchandise again this
is officially licensed by Marvel so they
have to approve every single thing every
word that goes on to this description so
all these are officially coming from
Marvel so let me know what you think
about all of these huge reveals that we
finally got let me know all of your
thoughts in the comments down below and
again don't forget to subscribe comment
and like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers endgame
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]